ich bin aber diesmal endlich wieder
recht optimistisch wir haben der zweite
kann nur mein name ist super und ich
spürte ein horrorspiel habe schritte
deswegen habe ich letztens mal gefragt
was wir sehen wollen und meinvz freddys
angst in diesem spiel geht es darum dass
wir einen job annehmen in einer pizzeria
unterhaltungsgeschäft wollen wir sind
halt in diesem laden drin
doch ans telefon meine fresse wir sind
auf jeden fall in diesem laden drin und
tagsüber ist es so dass da so figürchen
sind und so leute die so die kinder
unterhalten und zu sagen so heja kauft
unsere pizza entertainment macht so
spart von acht sitze ich halt hier und
muss schauen dass keiner zu mir rein
kommt dieser typ redet einfach die ganze
zeit überlegen was sie allerdings zu
wissen müsste ich bin ich was verpasst
ich sitze an diesem schreibtisch muss
aufpassen dass da eigentlich nichts
komisches passiert normalerweise soll
nichts komisches platzieren und ich muss
auf diese drei personen hier aufpassen
das sind trixi trucks wie und kiki unten
links seht ihr meine energie also 86%
usage ist so medium gerade ja ok der typ
hat gerade aufgelegt und wir sind jetzt
hier auf uns alleine gestellt und ich
bin jetzt schon voll am schwitzen wir
müssen glaube ich bis 6m überleben ist
gerade tut und die leute sind alle noch
da da freue ich mich auf jeden fall
gerade mal hart drüber ich habe mir
sogar extra kopfhörer in die ohren
gepackt damit das ganze so ein bisschen
authentischer für mich ist damit ich
mich vielleicht mehr schrecke aber ich
bin eigentlich ganz optimistisch und die
sind sitzen tatsächlich immer noch alle
drei in diesem raum da einfach drin doch
es geht ja gar nicht regelt
wahrscheinlich das spiel ist langweilig
oder so ich habe es auch noch nie
hochgeladen ich weiß auch gar nicht ob
habe ich das schon mal hochgeladen
was ist das für eine komische musik
es ist drei uhr nachts und ich hab noch
59 power und es sind noch alle drei da
ich bin einfach 500 freddys profi ich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht wieso man
usage bei einem grünen ball plötzlich
macht gar nicht sie sitzt sie einfach
nur rum ich würde am liebsten die lampe
da oben aus machen will
es ist vier uhr nachts die leute sind
immer noch da ist einer weg wo ist diese
per du du blöder [ __ ] du kommst nicht
zu mir dass uns weiter weg da ist
niemand auf der anderen seite ist auch
niemand drittes auch der dritte zum
glück noch da wir haben den camp 5
jemanden und in cam 7 und ich will dass
ihr euch nicht bewegt verdammte scheiße
camp 5 des ausgefallen ich habe an
ich habe definitiv angst hin kam ein
ziel haben wir jemanden wir haben in cam
7 jemanden und dem 1 okay wir wo bist du
er ist im garn verdammte scheiße was
mache ich denn jetzt lasst mich in ruhe
ok links kann ich theoretisch offen
lassen von da sollte eigentlich niemand
kommen noch immer 1 1 a der andere ist
ein c der andere steht direkt vor meiner
tür
wieso tue ich mir das an
wir haben immer noch einen zeh 1 a und 4
b es steht einfach direkt hier es ist
immer noch 5 m in der ersten nacht
freunde und meine power geht runter wie
sonst was ich meine fitness und
korrekter typ hier der allerdings
wir haben es geschafft glaube ich wir
sind jetzt in der zweiten nacht wo das
ganze jetzt wahrscheinlich nochmal ein
bisschen
wieso klingelt das telefon und ledigen
darf man gar nicht alles sehen
bisher noch gar nicht hier noch gar
nicht 18 also wir sind wieder hier drin
der titel aber gerade ganz ach ja da ist
schon jemand weg okay wir haben ihn auf
jeden fall noch okay darüber der zu ende
geredet ich bin aber diesmal endlich
wieder recht optimistisch wir haben
der zweite ist weg okay zwei leute sind
weg einer von denen es in 1 c und der
andere ist das hier schon blind spot
steht weil woanders finde ich den
tatsächlich gerade camera disabled alles
klar alles klar ich will es einfach
überleben ohne dass sich irgendetwas
drücken muss
wieso genau nochmals spiele ich dass ich
sage euch nur jetzt schon mal ich werde
nicht weiter
ich werde nicht weiter zocken als nacht
zwei jetzt gerade weil ich gerade in der
roda teil schon bei 5 20 minuten mit der
zeit will ich kann ich nicht mal diesen
ventilator oder ausstellen wir sie ein
bisschen kalt wenn ihr dann theoretisch
noch im nächsten teil haben wollt könnt
ihr mir das gut das kann nicht sein wir
haben in 1a jemanden 1b und 1c und wenn
ich hier die
ich habe an auch wenn ich ins 3d gucken
und in zwei a kanzler da kann niemand
sein you fucking state es tut mir sehr
leid um kohle aber das ist wirklich ein
spiel ich habe ich habe glaube ich noch
nie so ein spieler aufgenommen habt ihr
dieses spielprinzip eigentlich
verstanden also ich bin quasi hier drin
und kann nur mit meinem tablet schauen
ob die leute noch in ihren orten sind
und es kann alles sein wenn ich hierhin
1 abend wenn ich wieder auf 1b dass er
nicht mehr ist oder bei ncr nicht mehr
und die dann beispielsweise hier direkt
neben meinem links sitzen und wir wollen
mich hat die kamera und ausgefallen das
ist natürlich super ok ein space lab wir
haben ein ziel jemanden in 1 a
wo bist du verdammte scheiße da ist auf
jeden fall gerade niemand ich will am
liebsten über die türme eben zu lassen
weil dieser in er steht direkt neben mir
geraten
nein
auch immer das nächste mal kann ich
sogar continue nach zwei und quasi gar
nicht mehr muss ich noch eins machen als
wenn ihr das nächste mal wollte sich
dabei nach zwei anfang direkt und
zweiten partie bot haben wollt ich bin
halt eine pussy ich kann da nichts für
endlich haben keine horror spiele
spielen ich bin dann nicht für mich
geschaffen dann zeigt es mir trotzdem
mit einer bewertung und